have you ever thought about what the
world languages were 1 000 years ago
what influenced language expansion how
the used language or how much advanced
the language was
today's video will shed some light on
that and the main question asked by
professor john mcquarter
is what the world will speak in 2115
so welcome back to language shapes
perception if you're new here and you
like our content make sure to like and
subscribe to our channel
a century from now it's expected to have
fewer but simpler languages on every
continent in 1880 a bavarian priest
created a language that he hoped the
whole world could use he mixed words
from french german and english and gave
his creation the name volapuk which
didn't do it any favors
worse bolepok was hard to use sprinkled
with some odd sounds and case endings
like latin
it made a splash for a few years but was
soon pushed aside by another invented
language esperanto which had a lyrical
name and was much easier to master
a game learner could pick up its rules
of usage in an afternoon
but it didn't matter by the time
esperanto got out of the gate another
language was already emerging as an
international medium english
two thousand years ago english was the
unwritten tongue of iron age tribes in
denmark
a thousand years after that it was
living in the shadow french-speaking
overlords
on a dampish little island no one then
living could have dreamt that english
would be spoken today to some degree by
almost 2 billion people on its way to
being spoken by every third person on
the planet science fiction often
presents us with whole planets that
speak a single language
but that fantasy seems more menacing
here in real life on this planet we call
home
that is in a world where some worry that
english might eradicate every other
language
the humans can express themselves in
several thousand languages is a delight
in countless ways
few would welcome the loss of this
variety but the existence of so many
languages can also create problems it
isn't an accident that the bible's tale
of the tower of babel presents
multilingualism as a divine curse meant
to hinder our understanding one might
even ask if all humans had always spoken
a single language would anyone wish we
were instead separated now by thousands
of different ones
thankfully fears that english will
become the world's only language are
premature
few are so pessimistic as to suppose
that there will not continue to be a
multiplicity of nations and cultures on
our planet and
along with them various languages beside
english
it is difficult after all to interpret
something as intimate and spontaneous as
what language people speak to their
children who truly imagines a japan with
no japanese or greece with no greek
the spread of english just means that
earthlings will tend to use a local
language in their own orbit and english
for communication beyond but the days
when english shared the planet with
thousands of other languages are
numbered
a traveler to the future a century from
now is likely to notice two things about
the language landscape of earth
one there will be vastly fewer languages
two languages will often be less
complicated than they are today
especially in how they are spoken as
opposed to how they are written some may
protest that it is not english but
mandarin chinese that will eventually
become the world's language
because of the size of the chinese
population and the increasing economic
might of their nation
but that's unlikely for one english
happens to have gotten there first
it is now so deeply entrenched in print
education and media that switching to
anything else would entail an enormous
effort we retain the qwerty keyboard and
ac current for similar reasons also the
tones of chinese are extremely difficult
to learn beyond childhood and truly
mastering the writing system virtually
requires having been born to it
in the past of course notoriously
challenging languages such as greek
latin aramaic arabic russian and even
chinese have been embraced by vast
numbers of people
but now that english has settled in its
approachability as compared with chinese
will discourage its replacement
many world power has ruled without
spreading its language and just as the
mongols and manchester once ruled china
while leaving chinese intact if the
chinese rule the world they will likely
do so in english
some have predicted that mandarin
chinese will eventually become the
world's language
but its elaborate tones are too
difficult to learn beyond childhood yet
more to the point by 2 215
it's possible that only about 600
languages will be left on the planet as
opposed to today's six thousand
japanese will be fine but languages
spoken by smaller groups will have a
hard time of it too often
colonialization has led to the
disappearance of languages
native speakers have been exterminated
or punished for using their languages
this has rendered extinct or moribund
most of the languages of native
americans in north america and
aboriginal people of australia
urbanization has only furthered the
destruction but bringing people away
from their homelands to cities where a
single lingua franca reigns even
literacy despite its benefits can
threaten linguistic diversity to the
modern mind languages used in writing
with its permanence and formality seem
legitimate and real while those that are
only spoken that is
all but a couple hundred of them today
can seem evanescent and parochial few
illusions are harder to shed than the
idea that only writing makes something a
language considered the yiddish is often
described as a dying language at a time
when hundreds of thousands of people are
living and raising children in it just
not writing it much every day in the us
and israel it is easy for speakers to
associate larger languages with
opportunity and smaller ones with
backwardness
and therefore to stop speaking smaller
ones to their children but unless the
language is written once a single
generation no longer passes it on to
children whose minds are maximally
plastic it is all but lost we all know
how much harder it is to learn a
language well as adults in a community
where only older people now speak a
language fluently the task is vastly
more difficult than just passing on some
expressions
words and word endings the navajo
language made news recently when a
politician named chris deschen was bared
from leading the navajo nation because
his navajo isn't fluent one wishes mr
deshan well in improving his navajo but
he has a mountain to climb in naval
there is no such thing as a regular verb
you have to learn by hard each variation
of every verb plus it has tones
that's what indigenous languages tend to
be like in one way or another languages
grow in complexity the way that people
pick up habits and cars pick up rust one
minute the way you mark a verb in the
future tense is to use will i will buy
it an idiom kicks in where people say
i'm gonna go buy it or i'm going to buy
it because if you're going with the
purpose of doing something it follows
that you will pretty soon that gels into
a new way of putting a verb in the
future tense with what a martian would
hear as a new word gonna in any
languages that kind of thing is
happening all the time in countless ways
far past what is necessary even for
nuanced communication the distinction
between he and she is a frill that most
languages do without and english would
be fine without gonna alongside will a
language isn't something that can be
trimmed like a bush and children have no
trouble picking up even the weirdest of
linguistic frills
a click language of southern africa
typically has not just two or three but
as many as dozens of different cliques
to master native speakers have a bump on
their larynx from producing them 24 7.
for english speakers it seems hard
enough that mandarin chinese requires
you to distinguish four tones to get
across meaning
but in the hmong languages of southeast
asia any syllable means different things
according to as many as eight tones but
the very things that make these
languages so fabulously rich and also
makes it hard to revive them once lost
it's tough to learn hard stuff when
you're grown busy and self-conscious
there are diligent efforts to keep
various endangered languages from dying
but the sad fact is that few are likely
to lead communities raising children in
the language which is the only way a
language exists as its full self instead
many communities passing their ancestral
language along by teaching it in school
and to adults will create new versions
of the languages with smaller
vocabularies and more streamlined
grammars the irish gaelic proudly spoken
by today's english gaelic bilinguals is
an example something one might call a
new gaelic new versions of languages
like this will be part of a larger trend
growing over the past few millennia in
particular the birth of language is less
baroquely complicated than the
linguistic norm of the pre-modern world
the first wave in the development
occurred when technology began to allow
massive abrupt population transfers
once large numbers of people could cross
an ocean at one time or be imported by
force into a territory a new language
could end up being learned by hordes of
adults instead of by children as we know
from our experience in the classroom
adults aren't as good at mastering the
details of a language as toddlers are
and the result was simpler languages
vikings for example invaded england
starting in the 8th century and married
into the society children in england
hearing their father's broken old
english in a time when schooling was
limited to elites and there was no media
grew up speaking that kind of english
mandarin persian indonesian and other
languages went through similar processes
and are therefore much less cluttered
than a normal language is now these
languages can express any nuance of
human thought but they haven't existed
long enough to also dangle unnecessary
things like willfully irregular verbs
these are called creole languages it's
far easier to manage a basic
conversation in a creole than in any
older language
haitian creole for example is a language
low on the complications that make
learning navajo or hmong so tough
it spares a student from having to know
that both or male and tablets are female
which is one of the reasons that it's so
hard to master french the language from
which it got most of its word creola
languages were created worldwide during
the era that the textbooks call
western exploration african soldiers
created an arabic crayola in sudan
orphans created a german one in new
guinea aboriginal australians created an
english creole which was passed on to
surrounding locations such as again new
guinea where under the name takbisin
it is today the language of government
for people speaking hundreds of
different native languages jamaican
patois
south carolina's gula and cape verdean
are other examples modern population
movements are now creating a third wave
of language streamlining
in cities worldwide children of
immigrants speaking many different
languages or growing up speaking among
themselves or version of their new
country's language it's a kind of
compromise between the original version
of the language and the way their
parents speak it linguists have no
single term yet for these new speech
varieties but from kies deutsch in
germany to kebab norsk in norway from
the urban wall of of senegal to
singapore singlish the world is
witnessing the birth of lightly
optimized versions of old languages this
streamlining should not be taken as a
sign of decline
all of the optimized languages remain
full languages in every sense of the
term as we know from the fact that i'm
writing in one an old english speaker
who heard modern english would consider
it confounding and broken that any
language has all irregular verbs eight
tones or female tables is ultimately a
matter of accident not design hopefully
the languages lost amid all of this
change will at least be described and
with modern tools recorded for posterity
we may regret the eclipse of a world
where 6 000 different languages were
spoken as opposed to just 600 but there
is a silver lining in the fact that ever
more people will be able to communicate
in one language that they use alongside
their native one after all what's
peculiar about the babel tale is the
idea of linguistic diversity as a curse
not the idea of universal comprehension
as a blessing the future promises both a
goodly amount of this diversity and ever
more mutual comprehension as many
languages become easier to pick up in
their spoken versions that they once
were a future dominated by english won't
be a linguistic paradise but it won't be
a linguistic armageddon either
[Music]